c'est quelque chose qu'on a tenté que
plusieurs personnes ont tenté beaucoup
aux états unis avec en main un
relativement bon succès au canada aux jo
- cinquantaine de personnes qui ont
tenté construire des fauconniers des
grosses roches et puis le succès qu'ont
eue adapter très scénique j en fais une
personne à lévis où ç'a fonctionné
et puis ben il récemment à changer ou
les gens quand je peux nouveau d'or
courant des oiseaux sans utiliser un peu
mais presque moins que la cheminée est
utilisée autrefois donc c'est une
technique on aimerait bien réussir à
mettre au point mais qui pour l'instant
ne donnent pas les résultats qu'on
voudrait autrement dit on se prend
encore exactement quels sont les
critères pour le soin de la cheminée
pour le martin r non ce sont entre le
port on note que certaines idées
notamment une certaine dimension toutes
les conditions de température à
l'intérieur soit 76 ans on a cru que ce
soit à vienne à l'abri depuis si jamais
il pleut mais au barça on se pose
vraiment tout ce qui fait qu'un oiseau
choisi une cheminée plus tôt